me kevin smith have you been looking for
all my old podcasts the ones i started
recording back in 2007 well guess what i
found them
they're all hiding in that kevin smith
club all that shit's not exclusive
enough we got three more shows that are
only gonna be going on at that kevin
smith club the return
of plus one the marital podcast that i
did with jennifer for years wake and
bake
with kev that's right a video show where
every morning whatever i'm doing while
i'm smoking man you're gonna hang out
with me and then of course
the exclusive kev cast man that's the
podcast of me just by myself
or i just kind of do my own self therapy
while you listen
see all the video you've never seen
including exclusive movies and
live shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
if you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club now's your chance
to club kevin smith
hey welcome to the funny hat edition of
fat man beyond i'm kevin smith
i am sans hat mark bernardin
it's funny hat saturday kids
um i'm just switching it up this is my
movies cat
nice which we'll be making a little bit
available next year and stuff i'm not
selling because i can't sell them
because they're not available but
i do like it and i think i like how the
the
horns keep going when i don't i i didn't
know if that's
there was a like or the horrible cosplay
you were doing
but agar the horrible you old [ __ ]
man
[Laughter]
every every teenager in our audience
mark and you know they make up a lion
share of our audience
it's just like who is hagar the horrible
oh they're making old-timey references
and they're logging out and they're
going to watch grace randolph or some
sort of [ __ ]
welcome kids uh it's saturday and uh of
course uh me and mark are gonna
chit chat and go over to wanda vision
and go over all the news
everything that matters to folks like us
but before we do any of that uh if
you're on the east coast
monday jay and silabob secret stash
a comic book store that i have been to
and can vouch for
in red bank new jersey uh opens again we
closed uh
the secret sash the one the old one 35
broad street
that was in comic book men for seven
seasons um
right at the end of the year and ernie
o'donnell's building the new one down
the street at 65 broad street
and uh they're ready to open after you
know getting all their uh
the inspections and stuff like that
certificate of occupancy
uh ernie built a fake quick stop facade
in the back with the real quick stop
sign which we had in the old store
and uh iron bob is there as well it
looks amazing um
so it's not a grand opening on monday
there's no shindig or anything like that
but they're opening
uh at 10 o'clock and stuff we're looking
at maybe doing a grand opening thing
uh mid-march with me and jay going back
there and stuff
more on that when i know it but the
store itself opens on
monday man uh jay and sam bob secret
stash
so glad that it's it's uh finally back
uh
because we were we were gone for a
minute as we were building the new one
and stuff and uh
it's it's nice to to head into the 21st
century with the
brand new look of the place it looks
like phenomenal ernie did such a [ __ ]
good job views elsewhere on this channel
um if you never watch anything else on
that
on kevin's youtube.com kevin smith um
there's a series of like the making of
the stash
remaking the stash you could watch it if
you're that interested however
jermaine to our interests we we do love
comics and whatnot i have a comic book
store
so i'm here to let you know it's open as
of monday
thank you how are you mark what have you
been up to um well i've been i've been
uh
i've been good i've been writing a lot
it's been it's been a heavy writing
phase
i also saw your name in some uh marvel
thing uh comic book thing yeah i wrote
an issue of uh
they've got this big venom event
happening now called uh king and black
spearheaded by donnie cates and uh and
marvel
asked me if i would write um one of the
sort of companion books that went along
with it
um it's called uh planet of the
symbiotes
and i've got one issue in there that's
literally and i don't know if we talked
about it
the character that they're like hey are
you interested in writing american kaiju
and i said i don't know what that is and
they said it's a dude whose name is todd
ziller
uh pun fully intended um who takes
uh a kind of ramshackle version of the
super soldier serum
but instead of turning into captain
america he turns into [ __ ] godzilla
um but he's got like red white and blue
scales on his chest
all he ever says like when he's godzilla
he just shouts usa
at the top of his lungs
and so i uh and i'm like okay well
what's this story so you know he just
beats up a bunch of [ __ ] dragons that
are made of symbiote like
okay um that sounds like fun i can write
like 12 pages of just godzilla
destroying [ __ ] like cool as i could it
also be like a little bit of a
commentary on american exceptionalism
and they said if you can do it in 10
pages where godzilla is still crushing a
bunch of [ __ ] you can do whatever you
want
so that's kind of what it is it's like
todd's running monologue
wondering who's to blame for his lot in
life
like is it me for having agreed to take
the super soldier serum is it in america
for wanting to turn me into this
and whose fault is it there's you know
billions of dollars of property damage
and maybe tens of thousands of lies at
stake
i don't know the answer to that i'm just
gonna do what i do which is crush some
[ __ ]
um so yeah that hit stands uh last week
and then last week let me ask let me ask
you this
when you you got when you sell the
t-shirt that you designed you
send people to a website correct yes um
if i'm you i'm just saying
uh you got an audience here um and
and uh you know they were always looking
to support you and stuff like that
you've done other things you've written
other comics i would
set up a like mark bernardin.com and
[ __ ] sign every
thing i've written and you know what i'm
saying
like you're you're a smarter man than i
am
since when i hear like you got a comic
book coming out particularly marvel
comic book that's marketable my friend
um you could put yourself like one of
those deals
um which other comic book stores have
done in the past i think we're gonna
start doing it the secret session
where you can order like [ __ ] as long
as you order like a certain amount like
a thousand books or something like that
you get your own [ __ ] custom cover
that only you would have and you could
tag it and
[ __ ] sell it and stuff like that
we'll talk we should talk about as i saw
on twitter this week
um you you were talking about uh
somebody was i don't know how how it
came up but you were like
i said before i was this age i was gonna
direct
and now i'm taking a step toward that
are you wanting to i mean you talked
about
social media you want to talk about here
real quick yeah man i mean it's it's
it's the thing that i thought i wanted
to be when i grew up you know when i was
a kid growing up in new york
you know i wanted to be creative i knew
i couldn't draw you know i was a pretty
decent writer
but this was the the come up of sort of
indie cinema
um you know this is like david lynch era
this is spike lee error this is like
rusty cundiff and it's kind of john
singleton and that
that sort of like these are people who
just like want to make movies and
and this is their form of art and so i
love movies and so i went to college
fully thinking that i would graduate and
be a filmmaker that i would be a a
writer director
and then i made like three or four short
films in college and uh
and it was a painful experience because
nobody gave a [ __ ] about it as much as i
did like i'm the only one who cared if
it came out good because i know money to
pay anybody anything
so they were only incentivized as much
as i could buy them pizza which is
really no way to run a
to run train so i kind of abandoned
directing
like i was like well i'll just write
because when i write it's
it is as good as i can make it and
nobody else can make it any worse
until i they buy it from me and then
they can [ __ ] it up if they want to but
while it's on the page it's the perfect
version
that it's supposed to be but i always
kind of held it in the back of my head
that like you know at some point i would
really like to kind of
fulfill that version of my life and like
make something good and make something
real and so i said to myself about five
years ago because i would see a bunch of
like friends to
like i'm 22 and live in cleveland i made
a movie
i'm like well i'm 45 and i actually work
in hollywood like i should be able to
make this happen
um so i made myself a deal that i was
going to direct something before i
turned 50.
and uh and this is my 50th year
and so by november i will i will turn
that particular dial
and so i've got time you know like i'm
not going into an office
i'm not i'm not pulled in any of the
directions that i'm usually pulled in
and i had a lull in between the [ __ ]
that i was supposed to write
i was like well i want to write let me
just do it let me just write this short
like it's not gonna be a feature film
that's that's just not in the cards but
i could
i could finance a short if i had to like
i could pull together
enough enough money to put 15 minutes of
something
pretty cool on film and so last week i
finished that short
and uh and so when i'm writing it
i finished writing it and so now it's on
to the next phases which is
finding out how much it's going to cost
to shoot this thing that is widely more
ambitious than it should be but
you know [ __ ] it um casting it
finding the money for it hopefully this
will take long enough
but not so long that we can maybe shoot
it in like september
and maybe kovid will have receded just
enough so that the
the expense of having to covertize a set
isn't as much as it used to be
um but that's the plan man the plan is
to is to do the thing
is to do the damn thing because nobody
at the end of the day is going to hand
you the keys to what you hope your
future is supposed to be
um so i'm just getting behind the wheel
i'm going to drive it like i stole it
let me tell you a little story about an
independent picture i saw many years ago
named clerks i've heard tell
um oh you know me i love [ __ ] like this
i love when people who don't do a thing
do a thing particularly when they do a
thing and they get to a point where they
realize
why aren't i doing a thing you said it
you live in [ __ ] hollywood for
heaven's sake
like and it's not like when you live
here they give you movies kids but
like there are resources out here like
there's almost no excuse
uh to pursue that goal if that was
something you ever wanted to do and
apparently you do
uh that's [ __ ] tremendous i say you
indiegogo or
kickstarter or whatever the [ __ ] the
kids do these days
to finance man like i'll put in a bunch
of loot and you know
this audience would be like chi-ching
yeah as you figure out what it costs
that's
you know [ __ ] remember we [ __ ] raised
money
like here on the show a couple times
like we could literally do it
here you know raise a portion of it and
if not all of it depending on how much
it'll cost
yeah i mean it's that's that's the next
phase is you know i've got a i've got a
line producer friend who's grinding
through it
to see all right well it's gonna take
you four days you're gonna need to rent
these sets because again
it's not like we're shooting this in
somebody's house like it's a legit
that we decided to be built and we gotta
find standing sets that'll do this
you uh you wrote a thing that like
requires uh money i take it you you
didn't do that [ __ ] clerks thing
where you're like i'll
shoot it in a convenience store where i
work you're not shoot you didn't write
something for that tiny ass
wework office that we always see in the
background some sort of die hard
you know we work you know [ __ ] and sell
i did not
i did not you know got ambitious you
told you you got all george lucas on us
you wrote something with
[ __ ] wookies and spaceships you know
not quite spaceships and
it's funny like the the the idea came
actually because of you i don't know if
you remember this but we were uh
cinderella thing you're doing the
cinderella god damn it i'm telling you
that's a money idea
which idea um this was a thing we we
were in vancouver
um doing a show at the rio and you were
like hey
i got this call from these people who
are doing a tv show and it's an
anthology
and uh they want to know if i want to
direct one and i was like oh
that would be [ __ ] badass and he's
like they have this idea that they want
me to do and i think i'm going to stick
with that one but
if you got anything in the hopper you
know just whatever let me know what you
think of and like on the wait let's
let's tell them what it was
i mean if this was your deal not mine so
if you want to tell them strange because
i forgot about this until you mentioned
it because i was like what [ __ ] and
then i was like oh
i know that anthology show it was
twilight zone it was jordan fields
twilight zone and they were working on
season one
and while i was up there doing a super
girl like i
sat down with the producer and of the
show and whatnot and they were like yeah
man we love you we want you to come do
one and stuff
and then uh last i heard was like all
right not season one
maybe season two and then i never heard
anything back again
so go ahead yeah so so there was an idea
that they wanted you to do
and you were like all right that's cool
we can figure that out and so we'd be
battled around for a while and then on
the plane home
i literally just like [ __ ] spun out
this whole another completely different
thing
um and i was like hey man what about
this and you're like that's [ __ ] rad
and then they're like but they don't
want to do shows like this now they've
already got one of these in the first
season they don't want one of these
again
so i just [ __ ] put it away because
what the hell am i doing with a stray
twilight zone idea
but that's the [ __ ] short that i end
up writing is that stray twilight zone
idea
and i and i kind of love it um i kind of
love it so i'm really really excited
i can't wait to actually get into it and
and feel all of the fear
that i hope i get to feel which is all
these people are here expecting me to
know what i'm gonna do
and now i just get to lie to them and
tell them i know what i'm doing
yeah and you know what's nice about it
too is um we sit here every week
and uh sometimes advise our bettors on
how to tell their stories and [ __ ] like
that um
you know and then there's always that
leaves one
uh vulnerable to hey man you can't
[ __ ] you've never done it where's
your [ __ ] thing
now you get to be like here's my [ __ ]
thing um the other thing is
you're gonna have to [ __ ] thank
jordan peel in the credits
[Laughter]
thanks jordan i'll just do that anyway
all the time just you might as well just
cover your ass but like in this instance
it's fairly
[ __ ] warranted man that's awesome
[ __ ] i raise my
you know whatever these things are what
they call [ __ ]
masons my mason jar full of obvious
potato squeezings
actually this is just water i raised my
water to you and your wework cell
i can't wait to finance your movie along
with general public in the chat
everybody's uh going like i'll [ __ ]
put money into mark's thing so
yeah that's it's it's all incredibly
humbling and kind and generous
and i will absolutely take all of it
once we figure out how much we need
look at that kids mark's gonna make a
[ __ ] thing and i
i'm familiar with the story and it is a
[ __ ] thing
like it's it's not it ain't some clerk's
[ __ ] where he's just shooting in his
[ __ ] yard or whatever the [ __ ] it's
actually
probably more expensive than clerk's
three to be honest with you i'm
certainly more visionary to say to you
i mean yeah i i did the exact opposite
of that advice which is when you're
making a short film just write it around
stuff you already have lying around
like do you have a winnebago then she
said in winnebago
is it like that's why most of these are
like road trips because everybody's got
a car
or can borrow a car and it's like oh
it's a great american story we're
hitting the road
and then maybe there's zombies the
cheapest of special effects
uh you know what i would hold on
i would like to put money into your rv
zombie movie sir
this take all of this damn money that's
now it's fairly interesting
um all right kids we'll get into it man
because everybody's like uh
[ __ ] it's agatha all along uh
we uh watched wandavision um so you
don't have to no of course we all
watched juan division because
uh it's the best show on tv right now as
far as i'm concerned uh
gripping and uh teaching us patience
uh and uh the value of not getting
everything you wanted
at once right like as we're spoon fed
week by week
um we were prepared for an hour-long
episode some
somebody [ __ ] dropped that bomb last
week
[Music]
and apparently it's my fault yeah i'm
sorry internet
that you didn't get three one hour long
episodes everybody came at me on my
twitter
like you said it was an hour i was like
he said it's an hour
so uh it was neither from marvel nor one
division
exactly repeated something i heard on
the internet which turns out to not have
been true
which is how the internet works speaking
of which
jennifer lawrence is sue storm we'll
talk about that later on
um so we watched uh juan division and it
was absolutely wonderful episode uh
seven uh i'll be honest with you for the
first half
of the episode i was like oh man this
ain't as good as last week's episode
um but that's i think has more to do
with the fact that i
never watched a single episode of modern
family i mean i get the gist of course
of a two camera
break the fourth wall sitcom uh we've
been watching them for years obviously
but
uh my wife who uh jennifer who
loves wanda vision as much as i do and
went [ __ ] crazy for this most recent
episode
um she's a she was a big modern family
person and she was like
this was pitch perfect her performance
was pitch perfect
the shots were she was like this
couldn't have been more
modern family so most of the modern
family charm of that was
lost on somebody who didn't watch modern
family
um but uh we got
important things you know about 10
minutes into it or something like that
the first thing was the nexus commercial
was pretty [ __ ] huge
uh nexus commercial uh you know
following the
path of all the commercials that they've
done thus far on one of vision
um deals with some trauma in the past
that that wanda has gone with related to
incidents we've seen
uh play out across the marvel cinematic
universe but this time
that reference to the nexus is
you know in comics wanda is what's known
as a nexus being
so no matter what existence what
part of the multiverse she is a constant
in all of it makes her one of the most
powerful beings
in the world um i don't know if that's
what they're
saying with this nexus pill or if
they're just referencing
the multiverse which clearly that's part
of it as well
but like uh that would be massive that
means they're never gonna do
you know [ __ ] uh dark phoenix
with when they bring the x-men in
because they're they're
literally doing their own dark phoenix
uh with wanda
right now so uh that commercial was
a real eye-opener and at one point in
the episode she was popping the
pill did you see that and i think it was
the model the texas nexus
yeah right before uh uh monica
comes in let's talk about that huge
moment
in the show in which uh a hero
is born like he got to see monica
rambo's uh
secret origin as at least photon
if not on her way to perhaps a captain
marvel who she's been both in the comic
books
um what'd you think of the sequence
because that was great
like we rarely think about how
how rarely we actually see the birth of
a hero
anymore in the marvel universe like it
reminded me a lot
it was very star wars in a way because
you even got
like the voice overs from the voices of
her past like you heard
her mother you heard carol danvers you
even heard [ __ ] nick fury in there
like you're hearing the the chorus of
people telling her that she's been
special her whole life
she's been meant for something that like
you know you're just not you're the best
part of me
says mom you know like you're gonna be a
big bright shining star
it's my big dick i do what i want like
all that's in there
and when she emerges on the other side
with her weird-ass glowy electric eyes
like yeah and this is she's everything
on the electromagnetic field
um like at first and then she kind of
blinked it off and whatnot but
when was the last time marvel birthed a
hero
i mean i mean it's it's
spider-man and they didn't even show us
his secret origin
yeah the mcu he's just spider-man yeah
i'm not vision but vision we saw vision
be birthed in age of ultron
i mean famously scarlet witch
was already kind of had her power so she
was more introduced
um uh carol danvers in in captain marvel
we saw her origin
the explosion her absorbed powers but it
feels like it's been a minute since
we've seen the birth of a marvel hero
and they gave us one
in this show like so many people at the
beginning of the show is like
what are they gonna do they're probably
gonna save all the good [ __ ] for the
movies it's just gonna be like what
could they possibly give away
they literally brought a brand new hero
into the marvel
cinematic universe one that we know is
going forward into captain marvel
and it was a beautiful sequence um and
it was heroic
watching it pushed through the through
the wall i loved when [ __ ] like the
vehicle when that vehicle first came out
first thing i thought was that is a
fantastic car
and then i was like nope too early
[Laughter]
i was wondering i was like is that the
[ __ ] fantastic car because we're all
looking for like remember she talked
about the engineer friends so we're like
is it
reed is it sue is it [ __ ] victor von
doom is it uh
uh brashear the blue marvel or whatever
the [ __ ] so it's hank mccoy i heard a
lot of hank mccoy
it was the mac mccoy as well um so
the the the vehicle trying to go through
the wall was [ __ ] dope as [ __ ]
and like have and hearing randall park
be like it's being rewritten and like
that's just a [ __ ] cool concept
uh monica escaping at the last minute
and then
that you know the [ __ ] hex shooting
what used to be like this cool ass
vehicle and half now brown panel van and
[ __ ]
inside of the world as it was rewritten
and she has a moment where she looks
back
and she's like i can do it like i could
get i could still get through that
like that's [ __ ] superhero moment
right there and as you've got somebody
off there going
no monica you know calling out to you
not to [ __ ] do it and [ __ ] and she
pushes through the [ __ ] wall
that [ __ ] was dope it was phenomenal
especially for a show that's not
called [ __ ] monogram it's like we
didn't come for that
that storyline or the birth of that hero
and we got to
see that i thought that was really
awesome it was it was great bonsai
also there's something very like you
know oscillation over thruster
about all that i was like oh that's kind
of cool yeah
that's kind of dope seeing her confront
wanda
and seeing wanda's reaction like when
wanda pushed her back and then [ __ ]
like went to slam her down on the ground
and
monica kind of i guess landing
like yeah with the hero landing and [ __ ]
and like they
you see wanda like kind of gasp a little
bit like react to
like oh [ __ ] like you have powers and
whatnot general dean
yeah you changed and then uh of course
uh it gets interrupted the their their
little moment and [ __ ] because it looked
like monica was breaking through
and monica like just wants to like she
said
like i i i understand her and she as she
confronted wanda
she was talking about like i lived
through the worst the worst thing that
could ever happen to me
has already happened which we assume
she's talking about
the death of her mother but you know she
wasn't she didn't say that so it could
be a number of things but
let's assume it's the death of her
mother she's trying to relate to her to
tell her like i understand like you've
got pain and whatnot but like
this ain't the way and hayward's gonna
burn this thing to the ground to get the
[ __ ] vision
and he's gonna make you the villain and
then you know
wanda gave her like maybe i am which was
[ __ ]
dope because i'm like yes be the villain
be the villain man
like of course that'd be amazing if it
was like doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
if the whole [ __ ] marvel universe
turns on wanda he's become the
most superpower being and then of course
like you know they don't kill her she
gets some understanding or whatever the
[ __ ] but like
take it there man or they do or they
kill her no they can't do that what what
a terrible message and storyline that
would be
like hey little girls do you have the
power guess what you'll die for it one
day
you'll go crazy and you'll die for it so
they couldn't let it happen that way but
they could take her
to like you know [ __ ] to avengers
level threat villain and then bring her
back in the ante thanos
where she doesn't have to get beat but
she you know is defeated more or less so
who knows if that's what they're gonna
do but
i'm here for it i loved when she was
like maybe i am and she gave that
[ __ ] look and i'm like
yes girl yes lean into that [ __ ] all
these people
expand the wall bring it to jay and
sound bob secret set
back let's throw some comic books
yes where mark stuff will be on sale
sign um
agatha uh comes into play uh heavily in
the episode
the great uh kept secret in in all of
one division
it's almost as good as like khan
was in star trek too like who's been to
carmax playing he's playing con
no he's playing john harrison come on
guys
really but there's more room here than
there was in
in the star trek two remake in as much
as
two episodes left and she may not be the
big bad
she you know she may be like uh
who is in doctor strange uh [ __ ]
bernie eyes cause
casillas castelius kaiselius or
something yeah
bycilius was like our bad guy but who
was he working for
dormammu so perhaps agatha
is in league with you know when she
when when wanda goes into the basement
and we get glimpses of the room
including that book that looks like it's
right out of [ __ ]
um you know the the sanctum sanctorum
right out of dr strange
there's an empty little there was a a
meme that went around that showed like
all the
hexagonal jail cells for each one of
these books of power
and there's one that doesn't have a book
in it and then is that the one that
agatha has in her basement
and is that the whole that [ __ ] kevin
foggy playing six dimensional chess man
because doctor strange goes back a
minute
yeah so to be having to be [ __ ]
playing that to even have the hexes
the hexagons was like [ __ ] nuts so
agatha uh down in agatha's basement
when they looked up at the ceiling there
were different sigils
like it wasn't just one design it was
like a couple different sigils which
means
it may not be like she's in league with
[ __ ]
uh mephisto it may mean like she's a
conduit like
kaiselius to old
dark marvel gods man which would include
mephisto amongst them it could be more
than [ __ ] one
and it and it sounds like she's not
going to like
die you know at the end of this like you
know
some marvel villains just [ __ ] get
killed i feel like they're going to keep
her going for a long time i think
katherine
hansen for the long run no i mean it
would not surprise me if she
becomes the loki of this phase
which is oh the [ __ ] villain that we
kind of love to see
so much fun to watch we'll watch her do
just about anything
who presents as the first big bad guy
and then becomes a herald
for the actual big bad guy who's to
follow
and so that sort of leads me to believe
that maybe we don't get
mephisto here you know like if this is
if this is the thor movie where loki's
the big bad
you know then maybe [ __ ] agatha is
just a big bad for this
and we give her two more episodes to
just flex and then here comes doctor
strange who i'm pretty sure is going to
be
the luke skywalker level cameo we get at
the end of this
is going to be cumberbatch's doctor yeah
but it's paul bettany keeps saying that
like this
is some this actor is an actor he's
that that uh pietro was not the big
[ __ ] reveal the big cameo
and he said the big cameo is an actor
he's always want to work with and hasn't
worked with before
has did betany and and uh
and uh cumberbatch crossover in infinity
war at all i believe they did
so then i mean we know we're getting
doctor strange because we've heard for
you know ever that that cumberbatch is
going to be in this somewhere but
it sounds like there's still somebody
[ __ ] huge coming
within the next two episodes yeah
because because
cumberbatch dr strange was in space
dealing with you know weird space [ __ ]
in infinity war
when vision was on earth and in wakanda
trying to get the the stone
removed so they were never on the stage
together and then
vision dies at the end of infinity war
so he's not there for the big
rally in end game i would be
i mean you know look i'm happy i can't
wait to see doctor strange in this
[ __ ] but i'd be disappointed
if paul bettany was like the big actor i
was talking about is benedict
cumberbatch
what no no the best you can do
yeah your you need to dream bigger paul
bettany
um i i don't know who it'll be man but
um
like the internet i'm hoping it's uh ian
mckellen
michael fassbender like i'm looking for
a magneto
um i mean
you know maybe deadpool pops in who
knows
like could sky's the limit there's it's
got to be huge
there's an interesting thing i saw on
twitter over over the past week
talking about magneto specifically which
is
you know how do you reckon with the fact
that magneto
the the most recognizable trait of
magneto is that he's a holocaust
survivor
and so how do you
how do you modernize that is he still
going to be a holocaust survivor
and when you reintroduce him into 2024's
mcu like that would make him
90 years old at that point if he's aging
like a normal person
um so do you do you do some like comic
book magic where no magneto age is
slower because his body
the blood on his body moves more
efficiently because of the iron in it
and he can control it better whatever
you give some mojo on top of that
[ __ ] or do you
divorce that character from the
holocaust and give him a different
core wound i i mean i
i'm not to diminish you know [ __ ] the
rich
history of the character but you know i
the first thing he's got to be is
magnetic
that's it like at the end of the day you
know if you want to
change him from eric leshner you know
to you know aren't they from sokovia
and if he is their dad wouldn't that
make him also
maybe sokovian not you know i don't know
there
but i could see them i i could see it
having to work without telling that
version of the story i mean you're right
it's just
we're so far removed yeah so
does the sokovian attack become his core
wound
that's what i'm i'm thinking you know or
maybe not that the one that uh
you know the because it it couldn't be
the one from
ultron right because wanda's an adult
right and obviously like they keep
talking about
these commercials and how you know those
two actors are meant to be their parents
but then where would that leave
magneto if he did pop up i don't know
you know what let's not speculate let's
let's deal with what we got right now
what we got is
uh a classic marvel character
introduced for the first time into the
marvel cinematic universe
uh uh agatha harkness created by
stan and jack that's how far that
character goes back into like the first
100 issues
of fantastic four so
huge dude huge you know like i know
you can't do a wander story without
at least getting to ag of the harkness
at some point but
there's a world where they don't do that
you know what i'm saying like
like introduce an old [ __ ] marvel
witch
all depicted as like you know like aunt
may old holding the cat and [ __ ] like
that
it's kind of ballsy and genius to uh
bring that character in but also
like you're talking about a character
created by
two titans of a [ __ ] marvel
like you know in a world where we don't
get the stan cameo
going forward although one of the in the
opening credits for wanda vision when
they kept
doing the happy endings like rwanda over
and over
the license plate had stan's birth date
on it apparently that
their easter egg to stem but in a world
where you don't get to stay in cameo
you're getting you're getting stan and
jack created
character you know it's uh it's i'm glad
i'm really glad they chose this
character and i'm [ __ ]
super glad they chose katherine han
just look at the montage during the
song which was incredible the monster
sounding
agatha all along theme song every
iteration they do of her
she carries a completely different look
and like she if you look at her entire
acting history like
she's rarely just playing straight
katherine han
the only one we saw of straight
katherine hahn was the director in the
chair
like when wanda you know when she turned
around and looked at the camera and was
like that
that that's katherine hahn the rest of
them is like
she's she's like a woman of many faces
man like
and and i was as i was watching her you
know they just announced that nicole
kidman is going to play lucille ball
and i was like catherine hahn should
[ __ ] play lucille baldwin yeah
she's so great she's so great and it's
really nice to see
um to see a big gigantic titanic female
villain
kind of like come to the fore because i
don't i mean other than than
cate blanchett in in in ragnarok
i don't think they've had like a giant
big
lady bat um
and so just to see just and [ __ ]
captain hook she's like madeline kong
like she's gorgeous oh what a great
[ __ ]
that's a genius pull excellent illusion
yeah she's so funny and she's she's
beautiful and she's got crazy timing and
when she goes dark
like it's all there like she's gonna be
a lot of fun to watch for the next
couple of years as if not the big bad
then one of the big bads of this next
phase if it's all about magic
this totally makes sense think of her in
terms of the fantastic four kids
if uh silver surfer was the herald of
galactus
ag of the harkness is the herald of like
um
aside from mephisto was the guy i don't
even know how to pronounce it
yes like really old marvel characters
um who represent old dead gods and
ancient magic
it seems like after the first marvel era
was the era of science
of iron man and so forth and the
incredible hulk
and whatnot um now we're into the era of
like magic like they're leaning you know
doctor strange was definitely
a part of that as well but like they're
going they're leaning heavily into
their magical realms which like you know
really [ __ ] does it for me man
as much as like i really dug the doctor
strange movie
the one that they're setting up now like
you know
it's just i love the idea of multiverse
of madness because it feels like by the
time they get to
dr strange three it's definitely gonna
be sorcerer supreme
he's gonna elevate and [ __ ] and then
he's coming like in a show that's
already been breathtakingly good
we're going to get a [ __ ] doctor
strange appearance as well
um coming up within the next two [ __ ]
episodes so
um agatha uh or catherine um
as as mark was saying worst kept secret
in [ __ ]
in the pizza um turns out to be our big
bad or our mini
our mini big bad or whatnot uh you know
pietro or evan
evan peters uh obviously you know with
wanda saying this week that man is not
your uncle we know that he's not
meant to be the real pietro do you
think like based on the you know the the
first time they did a post-credit scene
in juan division
and it was monica looking around the
house opening up the basement that
purple energy
like [ __ ] crawling up the walls and
then all of a sudden
you know evan peters behind her in a
tie-dye shirt going snoopers gonna snoop
and then we cut out and she had like the
eyes her eyes went purple or whatever
so you know i don't think he's mephisto
um because why he was playing more of a
you know like a renfield kind of role it
felt like
in that moment like yeah in the in the
agatha all along montage
like it's clear that when he knocks on
the door he's got like
the purple shimmer on his back and he's
controlling him over her back
yeah like either she conjured him or she
manifested him or she pulled him from
the multiverse but it's all her
now in the comics like years you know
after
ag of the harkness was created um i
forget i forget who it was maybe len
wine or
i forget who marv wolfman maybe created
nicholas scratch who was her son
and that rabbit she's holding she called
them mr scratchy at one point
you're scratching in your scratchy so
you know you i don't know that you ever
saw the rabbit
and evan peters in the same place the
same time there's a world where evan
peters is playing her son
nicholas scratch so he's kind of like an
assistant or something like that
um and also like scratch is a is an old
slang term
himself the devil absolutely
she keeps referencing her husband ralph
a lot of folks online seem to think that
would be
reference to the devil that she's been
talking about like my husband ralph blah
blah blah
because witches as we know or at least
you know in [ __ ]
literature and dark witches like this i
ain't saying wiccans please don't write
letters or [ __ ] comments but
um you know just as a nun marries jesus
you know a dark witch marries the devil
so to speak so
could be could be ralph is meant to be
the devil
uh we'll i guess we're gonna find out
soon but i don't think evan peters is
mephisto i think he's an assistant
it feels like right now but who knows
where they go with that
yeah i mean if all one division does is
introduce agatha harkness
and and monica rambo as a superhero
that in and of itself is a lot of
[ __ ] work to have done
and also to get us further along on
wanda
sort of losing touch with reality and
unwilling to reengage with it when offer
the opportunity
you know like that's a lot of work for a
show to have accomplished and if that's
all they do and we don't get mephisto
until later
that's still plenty yeah it could be
setting the stage for the ancient
ones which would be like somebody like
mephisto as well maybe we don't get that
in the next two episodes
um certainly looks like we might get a
[ __ ] witch battle right
like you got two witches red magic
purple magic
it feels like and now you got monica
with blue
energy so it feels like we're gonna have
a color war in the next two episodes
right
they're gonna be doing this [ __ ] that
harry potter [ __ ] where they're like i
love whenever they [ __ ] cut to her
hands and [ __ ] and she's
like watch how you talk to me and she
gets ready and [ __ ] she doesn't
expect it i could watch that all [ __ ]
day long
um the theme song as the kids say
absolutely slapped my god it was so
[ __ ] good i hands down the best of
all the theme songs
that they had in the entire run of the
show all along
or all along was so good um and it feels
like they're done with the sitcom
premise feels like the next two episodes
there are there is no
sitcom presentation they referenced
something about there's no tv signal
coming out anymore so it looks like now
that we've reached current day
we're done with like the tv references
so the next two episodes would just be
straight up adventure
yeah straight up magic v sword
the hayward and i'm
i'm down with that like i i think it was
clever that they did with the tv shows
but like i'm done
like i just want i just want the
adventure now i just want the storyline
the main storyline
um you know like it was an interesting
it's interesting experiment right like
can we recreate
the vibe and the feel of these old shows
and also somehow make that part of the
texture of the drama
and like yeah you did it you totally did
it i don't i don't necessarily need you
to
now shift into like i don't know
again bob's burgers or you know
atlanta like i don't i don't necessarily
need that version
of this show just let's let's be
adventure let's just be [ __ ] magic
and science
and punching and grief
two episodes left to pack that all in
man
like i'll tell you um this is apropos
nothing have you watched
your honor on showtime i have not no
i've heard it's good though
it's amazing you would love it please go
watch it it's a writer's paradise
i was watching their season finale and i
won't spoil it at all but i'm watching
their season finale
and they were getting to like the end
and i kept [ __ ] like
clicking the remote to be like how many
more minutes are left
i'm like there's four minutes they're
gonna wrap this [ __ ] up in four minutes
um really great tv writing
does that they have like i you know i've
went back and watched
key episodes and moments across tv
history for the last like three weeks
and like what was the one i was most
fascinated
by i kept telling like uh jennifer i was
like
like oh tootsie i mean it's not a tv
show but
tootsie like in my mind the whole last
half hour of tutsi one of the greatest
american scream comedy screenplays ever
written
um takes place with you know um him
taking off the wig and [ __ ] revealing
that he's a man on live tv
and [ __ ] like that [ __ ] literally
happens in the last 10 minutes of the
movie
like the last 10 dude and you're like
what the [ __ ] like and then they fit
the entire day new ma into like six
minutes seven minutes
where you know he goes and sees uh
jessica lang's dad
uh charles what's his name um
charles durning and then you know that
in turn
sends him to go see uh julie as played
by
uh um i just said her name
um what's her name you know jessica
yes thank you just glad i smoked it away
and the entire [ __ ] emotional
like [ __ ] up everything
not just denu ma but the in crux
like the lesson of like you know him
saying
i think i was a better man to you as a
woman than i was as a woman as a man
whatever the [ __ ]
he's like i just got to learn to do
without the dress is in the final
minute of the movie like that
never like that's some good [ __ ]
writing dude where they can take it
right up to the [ __ ] credits and [ __ ]
so i think we're gonna get that in one
division we're like
right up until the last [ __ ] second
like they're gonna make you wait
for for details for everything and we're
gonna get a chunk of [ __ ]
in the last four minutes of the next of
the last of the second episode of the
of the last two that are coming up
something feels like that because then
think about it
that nourishment has to take us all the
way
to two weeks later we [ __ ] even
soldier i don't know
all together it's got it the wanda story
will stop
temporarily until we get to doctor
strange yeah
so you know it's there you know
thankfully we will have
uh as you said the falcon and the uh
winter soldier to like
distract us but it's gonna be a minute
before we get back to the wanda story
unless they [ __ ] with it in loki
because in loki they're dealing with the
tva the time the time variance authority
and if wanda is [ __ ] with the
multiverse
that could include them as well maybe
yeah i mean of of the two i think loki
has the better chance
to to be you know in any way dovetailing
with with wanavision
because i don't feel like falcon winter
soldier has
the capacity for magic it feels just
very like
there might be like a reference to like
shit's going on in jersey but that's
about it
it feels more like you know what if the
a-team was superheroes and like okay
cool and also mission impossible like
it's just very action-oriented and not
deep trauma magic [ __ ]
um i did not watch um
the uh mandalorian after shows where
they like
set creators down or show you how they
do it and [ __ ]
but i are they doing that for this
because i would watch every second of it
behind the scenes
they are doing a an episode after
the finale which is like the making of
basically i don't know if it'll be part
of the disney
gallery which was the umbrella for the
mandalorian
um behind the scenes stuff and they did
like nine mandalorian things
um which are all interesting the one
that i found the most interesting
because i'd never seen it in action
before was the one about the volume
about like
here's our stage here's how it works
here's the evolution of it you know
all the way from jungle book you know
straight through to this and like that
[ __ ] is just amazing
and so i i don't know if they're doing
that deep dives into it but i think
we're definitely
getting one i don't know how long it is
i don't know if it's half an hour i
don't know if it's an hour i'm making no
promises on length of anything ever
again
a fresh ingredient in chat just brought
up zemo
though he was great in civil war that's
what's gonna [ __ ]
do it for me on falcon and winter
soldier is i'm a
him pulling on that i thought he was a
great [ __ ] character one of the best
marvel villains they ever had and [ __ ]
never put on a mask nothing but we see
in the trailer he's got the [ __ ]
classic mask
yep i can't wait to see that [ __ ] and
whatnot and they got daniel bruhl back
so i'm like that that i mean i'm i love
talking in the winter soldier don't get
me wrong but like i'm i'm
[ __ ] hard for the barons emo
storyline
so glad he's alive [ __ ] like you know
so often like
you know like killmonger's dead at least
for now and stuff
but this fucker's alive and they can
keep [ __ ] telling stories with them
and bring them back like that's pretty
dope
yeah i mean it's it's the benefit of of
not of us not seeing them kill a
character
you know and also they made a big
[ __ ] stink about you know
no we're going to put you in jail like
you know i i don't want revenge anymore
you pay for this for the rest of your
days and then he's gonna get so he's
gotta bust out right
and that's that's so [ __ ] comic book
bro
like because generally speaking they
don't in these movies they haven't
re-encountered people you know what i'm
saying like
they vanquish an enemy then there's a
new enemy and then to their credit in
the marvel cinematic universe
they've just escalated and escalated to
the point where it's like
you know can you imagine [ __ ] iron
man facing
you know well obviously he's dead now
but um could you imagine iron man
refacing
[ __ ] you know uh justin hammer or
something
like that you know bringing him back
from the grave
hey look that we got his big suit back
like you know they
they didn't have to they were never you
know it wasn't like rocky
two where they're like he's fighting
apollo creed again
they just kept building and [ __ ] and
went away from all their bad guys you
know some of them died and [ __ ]
or got killed or disappeared into time
like [ __ ] uh
red skull but like you know this is an
instance where they put someone's ass in
[ __ ] jail
and that ass is getting out of jail just
like in the comic books because how many
times the avengers [ __ ] like captured
zemo
he eventually got out and fights him
again so i love that aspect of this as
an old-time comic book guy
the notion of like they're gonna [ __ ]
face him again
like he's coming back i hope they
[ __ ] keep doing that i think it's
dope
yeah it's very low-key um and as long as
you've got good reasons to bring those
characters back like i don't really want
to see the dark elves again
never fine with that yeah yeah he was
great and
his legitimate gripe against superheroes
um
is enough to keep driving that character
and it's enough to hold up to
repeated instances of conflict like i
get that 100
they could for for me man like if they
could if you could custom title the show
i would literally call that [ __ ] baron
zemo on my [ __ ]
my cable service provider that's what
i'm there for
like [ __ ] are these episodes are half
an hour or long do we we have no
idea what they are again i make no no
statement whatsoever on length of
episodes part man you better not man
they'll be
after you again um yeah i
i hope they got zemo in every episode i
hope at the end of every episode he
pulls that mask on again
over and over and over that's my porn
that's what that's my only fans
if [ __ ] zima opened up and only fans
where all you paid him to do is
pull the mask the sound is all like
stretchy and latexy asmr and [ __ ]
and he's just going i hate superheroes
i hate him so much oh i'd pay for that
[ __ ] hardcore
holding money for that [ __ ] as they say
um all right
let's uh we've talked about wanda vision
and uh
two thumbs up as our bettors used to say
in the past
man uh they're on the [ __ ] right
track what a great show
and uh i'm sad to see that it's gonna be
ending but two episodes left two
two two episodes left gonna be huge
uh mark you got any news for us
there's a there's a there's a suicide of
news this market bernardin is an old new
sound and stuff he's about to be a
filmmaker as you heard but back in the
day
he was a news man and so he knows how to
get his nose
into the news uh ladies and gentlemen
give it up for mark bernard he's going
to bring you the news hello
so yes the the the rumor that broke
today so we might as well hit it because
it's today was that jennifer lawrence
was spotted
um either traveling to or arriving in
australia like today this is all over
twitter
this morning and this afternoon like and
i guess
one of the specious uh sites
one of the sites that's not necessarily
known to be 100
accurate all the time i think it might
have been daily mail i'm not sure yeah
daily mail online ran a story where uh
they said that she is going to australia
for a fantastic
war movie yes in which she has been cast
as sue richards now
when i first saw that i was like that
makes absolute sense
um except i i don't think there's a
script yet but i mean i don't [ __ ]
know i don't work at marvel or anything
like that but i ain't heard tell of
nothing
and like you know not even in the press
but i keep my ear to the ground just for
like you know i got an agent
i got a manager like you know i know
people who work in this business and
[ __ ]
and i'm always you know i just keep a
distant curious like what are they doing
how's it going and [ __ ]
not looking over the fence because i
don't like to be spoiled but you know
i ain't heard nothing i'm not grace
randolph that's the second time i've
invoked grace during this show
i know no well she's so good at her job
i feel like you got a great
job i'm not being facetious i actually i
read grace's tweets all the time
and go like how does she [ __ ] know
that um i'm
i'm not uh it was such a long preamble i
forgot the point i was trying to make
uh i i will say like i have no inside
information whatsoever
but realizing that john watts who is
directing
um fantastic four is also directing
spider-man 3
as we speak as we speak you know which
either it just wrapped or is still in
production for all we know
um and even if it just wrapped he's
facing at least
eight or nine months of post on that
movie
come here i'm gonna whisper something
you lean closer yeah what you got
what if john watts who's directing
spider-man
and is also directing fantastic four
knows who his sue storm is going to be
in fantastic four and is popping her in
for an appearance in the spider-man
multiverse movie
could be you buy that that works maybe
you know or maybe she's flying down
there to shoot a cameo
uh in love and thunder which is
currently in production in australia
well let's talk about the rumor itself
though if
she was indeed cast as uh sue storm
let's imagine for a second that she was
this breaks with tradition
for marvel because generally they don't
they're not like uh
how much you want give all of it
that enough you know they they kind of
with you know
they play moneyball where they used they
used to back in the day to be fair
um since you know the dignification
since disney came in whole hog
and you know marvel is their chief
earner
maybe they're not so you know let's play
moneyball anymore maybe they are in a
place where they're like look
going forward you know
you want to [ __ ] blow the doors off
on the fantastic four
and really [ __ ] introduce marvel's
first family cinematically
you can't get any bigger more famous and
more beloved than oscar winner
uh an adorable stumbler on stairs at
oscar's ceremonies
uh jennifer lawrence one of the most
talented people on the [ __ ] planet so
makes sense that's why i didn't read and
be like this is horse [ __ ]
to me i'm like that makes sense yeah
it's totally a way to go yes um
my one thing is that yeah i mean marvel
could do that
but i don't think marvel has to do that
you know marvel has done incredibly well
by just you know who's the star of these
things the characters these actors are
playing
like yes paul rudd is incredibly
charming but people are here because
ant-man is going to tie into
the avengers at some point we're here
because captain marvel means something
yes brie larson is a fantastic actress
and she's also got herself a shiny oscar
but we know that we're going to make 800
million dollars making a captain marvel
movie
not to say it doesn't matter who's
playing her but we don't have to try and
buy
an audience by casting somebody who's
expensive but
a draw marvel's the draw yes
and now some people you know uh have
you know the reaction of course online
as it is in the chat room
is divided some people like i'll watch
that all day long man because she's
insanely talented
uh then there are some people who are
just like the [ __ ] she hated playing
mystique
uh i don't think she hated playing
mystique she did hate
putting on all the [ __ ] makeup like i
remember one of the movies
she she was talking about like it
literally takes eight hours to do all
that body makeup when they did the shots
where she's fully
you know [ __ ] in in mystique look and
stuff so
you know i don't know
that you're talking about a woman who
has had a franchise already
remember like shouldered katniss and the
hunger games
through every iteration so knows how to
handle a franchise and
i i i i just think you're right like at
the end of the day
unless she was like look i just want to
do this for cheap like i won't even
charge you full freight i've always
wanted to be sue storm
she's gonna cost a lot of money to them
and if you're instituting her as sue
storm
you're with her for 10 years like sue
storm fantastic forgive me around for a
red hot minute
so um i you know i think
it's a it's it's i wonder i mean it
would make sense but at the same time
they
tend to like to make stars who they then
you know claim as their own like these
actors are at least as presented are a
very
tight-knit you know family and stuff now
it's not like marvel's not a heat seeker
you know uh they cast people
who have been standouts and and movies
like that you've got hawkeye
because he was in uh you know hurt
locker and [ __ ] like that and he had his
moment
and boom they're like oh we're gonna
hire that guy they do that with a lot of
folks like you know heat seek and and
cherry pick and stuff like that uh
nobody's like you know
jennifer lawrence is not like hey this
undiscovered town my whole
[ __ ] world knows who she is and stuff
so
you know it's you could i could see it
if it was the case
it just doesn't sound like something
they normally do but if it
is the case then you know boy oh boy man
they are
that that's them going like we're gonna
make a billion dollars with this
franchise
yeah because like it's fantastic four is
an ensemble
so now you've got to cast through other
people with whom
can stand up to jennifer lawrence and
and play opposite them so
now you're not just talking about like
oh hey we found some you know cute
little new zealand kid to play
reed richards and oh here's some some
totally unknown guy to play
johnny storm it's all right well now the
jennifer lawrence what's
i don't know what's [ __ ] mcavoy doing
does he want to be reed richards
maybe she was mystique he was professor
x it doesn't matter
so let's just do it all i don't know
like
i get it with captain marvel like
because carol danvers is the lead of
that movie and so yeah it's getting a
big hunk of movie star
but it's a bit like will smith in the in
suicide squad
so one of these is a movie star and
everybody else is kind of fine
and like it kind of gets out of whack
but brie larson is a great example like
brie larson
um was coming off of
roon right did she win she won an
academy award
so she was the actress of the moment for
that performance and then she walked
away with [ __ ] oscar gold
and marvel was like zoo bam so she
i mean gifted as [ __ ] but she wasn't
even like you know oh my god [ __ ]
that that puts asses in seats like she's
guaranteed money
right even there they they you know she
i'm not taking anything away from what
she did prior to captain marvel
she obviously you know was well she'd
been in some
a lot of movies but marvel made her a
[ __ ] star
like by putting her in the role of
captain marvel again not taking anything
away from rome where she won
an academy award so obviously that
star-making performance had a big
a lot to do with it but like they in
this instance in my head
marvel made her a star jennifer lawrence
is this franchise is under her belt
yeah she's as big as it gets it would be
you know like it would be like if they
made these movies in the 90s and cast
julia roberts you know you did you like
well i guess that makes sense she's the
biggest movie
star on the planet a female movie star
on the planet but i just i don't know if
if that's the case if if it is like them
shooting
if it's john watts shooting her for you
know
an appearance for a movie he's going to
make down the line and he knows that
it's her and [ __ ] like that and this got
out and
it's shaped in a different way that'd be
interesting
but i i don't i don't i don't know if
this is the
story i just think with the fantastic
four this time around look they've made
fantastic four movies before and which
one of which made a bunch of money the
second one i guess didn't do as well
this is you know them bringing marvel's
first family into the marvel cinematic
universe
part of the reason that disney paid
seven what 100 billion dollars or
whatever
[ __ ] for fox was so that they could get
you know not just the mutants and then
the x universe but also the fantastic
four
so i just think like like
i don't i you know i think they're they
have an opportunity
since we've seen other iterations before
they have to reinvent this [ __ ] thing
now granted story wise it's going to be
reinvented
and in the marvel universe we know it's
going to be like a thousand times
better just you know not [ __ ] on the
previous
fantastic four movies but we we're all
drawn into the marvel soap opera and
it's like
oh my god they get to play with those
toys now like holy [ __ ] it's gonna be
amazing
but you know it feels like they're gonna
do something different with it
and i just don't know if like jennifer
lawrence reads as different you know
what i'm saying
yeah you know and i think that that
whatever it is
the headline of this story is somewhat
disingenuous and probably not true which
is
jennifer lawrence heading to australia
to film new fantastic four film
yeah i i don't believe that that's why
she's there
um you know happy to be wrong because
that means we're getting fantastic for
way sooner than i thought we were but
you know if she's
there to film a cameo with sue storm in
something else that's cool
um but it does not it doesn't quite seem
possible that they're actually in
production
on fantastic four right now
agreed absolutely agreed um
okay let's talk um about the
uh big big story this week that just
the internet by storm and also like this
happened after we did our show
um so we couldn't talk about it uh they
dropped that snyder cut
trail yes which
my good lord zack snyder could run for
president right now and probably
get elected like there's such enthusiasm
trailer looks great uh amazing uh the
you know first i was like why is it 4-3
but i guess this is the
um imax cut we're getting
i guess so i mean all of the trailers
have been in like weird aspect ratios
like they were designed for instagram
sharing it felt like
i read somewhere that it was about this
this is the imax
imax is is not generally presented
widescreen it's presented in a massive
imac screen which is
generally one three three that's why
when you see those
sequences on like you know [ __ ] uh
the dark knight
where you know it opened like this and
then went
with the the robbery because that was
shot in imax and then when the movie
began they went back to its
proper aspect ratio if i remember
correctly
um same thing uh here but
this i guess this was the entire cut was
this was intended for imax it's not like
hey we did
certain scenes he shot the whole thing
like that i mean i
i don't know but it seems like so much
of what we saw
was cg or cg augmented anyway
that like yeah you could totally just
blow out
those sequences to fill an imax screen
if you've got the data
you know it's like when we went to to go
see um black panther those screen x
theaters where you know suddenly you
have
the regular movies here and then on
selected sequences
suddenly the entire sides of the theater
would become a screen
and it's all new visual information it's
all new cg [ __ ]
but it's like oh okay i guess you could
build more of that if you wanted to it
is jungle over here or it is
beneath the is on the underground
railroad or it's wherever
it's like that's cool that you have that
[ __ ] so maybe that's what zach did
i don't know we got to see uh you know
we've we've seen images
uh that he releases i guess over vera or
or uh
this is social media but uh we got to
see
uh dark side granny goodness dasad all
together in a frame moving
when seeing uh steppenwolf kneel
and stuff and his armor coming off uh
his armor looks very pokey
very sharp not practical yeah
um he uh we've saw the bat the batmobile
some people this week
started saying they saw pieces of
charlie
hunam or hanum as as green
arrow do you hear this [ __ ] i did not
hear this [ __ ]
i don't know if this is accurate or not
um but uh somebody was saying like oh
man he's in there too
um you know i i mean at this point
i wouldn't be surprised that was the
case last week we were talking about
uh ben and i was like i don't think ben
went back for reshoots
and then everybody was like you're
[ __ ] wrong and they were all right i
was wrong he did go back
for reshoots and stuff uh back in i
guess december or something like that
um so who knows who else came back as
we've already seen
you know jared leto returns as the joker
and much better looking joker than than
the last time when he had words written
on his face
and uh he literally quotes the internet
and he says we live in a society uh
which was you know grade a trolling
uh on behalf of zack snyder again i
think i said it last week i just
zack snyder must be like larry flint
in the people versus larry flint when
every network was running coverage
of him at once and he was just spinning
around in his chair
like howling at the ceiling like all of
the attention
uh of pop culture is on this movie which
he didn't get to finish and then he had
he saw somebody else
[ __ ] butcher and [ __ ] like that like
as a
filmmaker i know some people like i
don't like that movie so i'm not gonna
like
four hours of it and stuff and then
there's some people who are like i
worship at the altar
but regardless of what your opinion is
of the content
as a filmmaker you know and as a
filmmaker who's made some [ __ ] that
got ignored or [ __ ] like fell apart
or you know didn't get received the way
i hoped
there's a sense of like good for you man
go get them like you know rarely do do
people get a victory lap in this life
when they've not had a victory and with
this
project one could easily say he did not
have a victory it
left his hands you know he left the
project it was taken from his hands
so to see him not only like get to like
come back and not just do like a oh
here's a few scenes that you know warner
bros let me put in
they gave him a lot of [ __ ] money
like a lot of money
to like go complete his vision and and
now we're gonna get a four-hour [ __ ]
cut of this thing man
i have so much weed stockpiled because
i'm watching it straight through
i you know i talk about like you can
pause it and take a [ __ ] it'll make it
better
i'm gonna just sit here and be like i
got a big ass 103 inch television
in my bedroom and i generally you know
we've been watching wondervision on it
i'm going to be
i'm totally just going to be like i mean
it ain't lit so i won't get in trouble
just like you're like the tony montana
of weed just giant
mountain of [ __ ] weed and you're just
sitting there it's gonna make a good
thing
even better as far as i'm concerned i
spent
i spent a decent chunk of this past week
under the misapprehension
that it came out on thursday like
i literally was like it's march 18th
where's this [ __ ] thing we're gonna
talk about it on saturday's show i know
it
and mark was texting during the week he
was just like you know
and i guess we'll review the schneider
cut and i'm like you gotta
you got a [ __ ] cut of the movie how'd
you get a link
and then he was like oh that's next
month i was like we just got the trailer
[ __ ] that's all for real was like
it's march 17th it's coming tomorrow and
there i am at like midnight like
refreshing my [ __ ] hbo max going like
where is it come on guys it's the 18th
where's my [ __ ] movie
in a little like two days here hbo max
how dare you
not give me the movie a month ahead of
time
i was so close to going on twitter being
like anybody else having problems
finding this night okay
i almost did that on [ __ ] friday
night at 1202
because i i couldn't get wanda vision on
my laptop
but i could get it on my phone and you
know i was like look i'll consume it any
way [ __ ] possible but at the same
time
as i sat here and watched it on my
[ __ ] phone i couldn't watch it in the
103 and three inch tv because my wife
was [ __ ] sleeping she fell asleep
so i'm in my office and i'm looking at
my phone screen
but then here's my laptop mocking me
you know and then after the show i guess
it was 15 minutes into it finally it
like kicked on my laptop like it finally
found it but then i saw afterwards a few
people had the same problem
think about it man that's like the whole
[ __ ] world then now they got
i think they said 95 million subscribers
like they're almost at 100 million
subscribers disney plus
everyone hitting that [ __ ] at 1201
yep because we're like what the [ __ ]
gonna happen like you know
disney plus for 10 minutes is what i
heard is that right so it was a thing
yep in the same way that that uh then
luke cage crashed
netflix um is the same thing that
happened with wanovision
you know what they gotta do since they
ain't using those theme parks anymore
they gotta level those theme parks turn
them into server farms man
massive [ __ ] server farm so that we
never
never have a glitch like this ever again
uh what uh so yes so snyder cuts coming
kids that trailer
uh looks phenomenal looks like they
spent all the [ __ ] money and whatnot
um uh and uh we now we got less than a
month
to wait i wonder if they'll put it on
like hbo
has an awards site like if
i guess if you're in the industry and
[ __ ] that's where i watched a few things
early
i wonder if they'll put it up there
early man i mean i
i don't know i i don't know
i don't know i don't even know when the
[ __ ] oscars are i don't know when
the i mean there will be screeners for
it i think at some point but i don't
know where those screeners will
or maybe it won't this is this is a
thing that isn't going to matter
i feel very disconnected i mean i'm
never connected to the academy awards
but i feel very disconnected from
awards season this year like you know
it's it's people sent so many screeners
and you know as they do every year but
they sent screeners for everything that
i could already watch like
amazon and netflix they must have a lot
of money because they send out so many
dvds and it's like
kids i can watch it for [ __ ] free on
your i'm already paying for your network
like
yeah don't send this but the one
movie that seems to be getting a lot of
attention uh nomad land
directed by wha uh who directed
uh the uh eternals right so she's got
that coming
this movie's getting all the [ __ ]
awards she just broke some sort of like
uh crazy ass like record of like
um for this many awards for
a female screenwriter i don't know
whatever the exact
category was or whatever but she
cleaning up and and cleaning up like
for for not just the movie and directed
but for screenwriting
and she also wrote eternals if i
[ __ ] remember correctly so that's a
good sign man that's a movie that i'll
be honest with you that is
not like [ __ ] high on my radar i was
very disconnected from that
that title i never read a single issue
of eternals never followed
many of the characters or anything so
i'm not it's not as baked into my dna as
every other marvel
project that we've seen before but her
getting all this attention on nomad land
is really making me be like
this [ __ ] eternals might be something
you know marvel never
lets us down but it's nice that like you
know
how often they let like some first-time
filmmaker or a recent filmmaker that
they pluck
or sundance kid or something like that
let them write the script as well
like i mean i think marvel in the in the
very same way they do with their actors
are starting to moneyball their
directors as well and their filmmakers
like
you know ryan coogler like he had two
movies under his belt
when he did black panther like fruitvale
station and creed
and it's like hey would you like to do
this giant 200 million dollar movie he's
like [ __ ] yeah i want to do that like
chloe's out had made
you know nomad land i think you know was
in the can
maybe when she got the job it hasn't
been released yet and there's another
smaller movie she did i think called
mustang or the mustang or something
about rodeo riders
um and then like yeah come and do the
eternals they're like [ __ ] yeah i'll
come to the eternals like they you know
the half nelson
guys you know this last lady captain
marvel yeah
captain marvel like they're being i mean
taika waititi is not the first choice to
make
he was coming off of like uh the wilder
people with the wilder people yeah
you know like he had like two or three
very good but very small
new zealand movies i think i really i
bet you it comes down to like whoever
catches kevin
feige's attention these are the people
that films that kevin feige has enjoyed
which just says that kevin feige doesn't
like a single [ __ ] thing i've ever
done
[Music]
um yeah man i can't wait to see that a
bunch of cats in the chat are asking
about
uh mortal kombat you watch that trailer
i did watch that
come on that shot where [ __ ] sub-zero
stabs
uh that [ __ ] and the blood comes
out and it turns hard and then he stabs
him again with it
maybe like look i was saying i ain't
paying attention to the oscars
give that movie all the oscars right now
that is one of the most incredible
visuals i've ever seen in my life
it is such a [ __ ] you it's like i'll
kill you
take your blood and kill you again with
it [ __ ] you
oh my god don't expect that movie to be
any good at all
and yet i will 100 see it the minute i
can just give me that scene
just do that in every scene somebody
stabs somebody the blood comes out it
freezes
and then they stab him with that again
that [ __ ] was so metal
i honestly i didn't give a [ __ ] about
that movie until i saw that scene and
then i was like
then i says this i said hey hey mortal
kombat
somebody asked on chat they're like why
do you always have money laying around
for this reason kids it's a prop i'm a
prop comic
like i'm only carrot top only way less
poor
more poor he's super rich he's got the
biggest money
and way less jacked yeah [ __ ] i ain't
got the [ __ ] gun show
that he has at all i've got uh i've got
the slingshot show going over here
you know what i did watch i watched
judas in the black messiah
isn't it great so good so great man
such a good i mean the performances
absolutely top-notch
production value crazy good um the the
tone of the movie uh the neverending
sense of dread
um consistent throughout really really
well done flick
yeah i highly recommend it like if
you're if you're if you got the hbo max
you've got it access to it for another
20 days i think
before it disappears did you watch the
new ro
what was the name rosman pike movie uh
yeah yeah
i care a lot i think it's called peter
dinklage is in it
watch it yeah as a writer
watch it it's interesting it they they
take a deplorable [ __ ] character
and make make that character the lead
and there are moments in the movie where
i'm like i hope this character i hope
nothing good comes to character i hope
the worst things happen to this
character
oh my god she's evil and then they have
you flip
where you're just like oh my god i hope
she's okay but
it's it's very interesting what they
were able to accomplish with that movie
she's wonderful in the movie all the
performances top-notch
movies great uh utterly [ __ ]
watchable
um and completely [ __ ] satisfying by
the end of the movie
i was like i i they were headed in a
direction where i was like all right
well i get it and this is clever
but they [ __ ] satisfied me like at
the like
almost like tootsie in the last four
[ __ ] minutes they wrapped it all up
and [ __ ]
tootsie good that's what i say about
this movie is tootsie good
i didn't get what she rolled again most
kids are like tootsie what are you a
grandpa
tootsie is a great movie why do you
think they haven't tried to remake that
man
like you could totally remake that movie
today um i i
i don't know i mean i think that it's
that he misses doubt fire
be like well this is a doubt
and mrs doubtfire though i can't see
them ever redoing because robin williams
beloved
and and uh you know that and him having
passed away
seems like that would be sacrosanct but
the other one tootsie
like nobody talks about that movie
anymore except old people like me
it just seems like it's ripe for
remaking for some youngster i'm not
saying do it
hey kids go watch the original it's
amazing like it's it's one of the
greatest movies ever made
yeah um all right whatever yeah what
else we got
news um jj abrams is producing a new
constantine show for hbo max
is that well you know what good because
that character could probably
go very very far particularly in a like
uh grown-up setting if you were doing
like a dark
you know hbo [ __ ] r-rated hour-long
i could totally [ __ ] see that i've
always loved
uh hellblazer um one of the first comic
books i started collecting when i came
back
two comic books um jamie delano run i
just started if i remember correctly
and um he was introduced of course by
alan moore in the pages of the swamp
thing i was a massive swamp thing fan
so they had the keanu movie which i
think jay and solomon bob are referenced
in if i remember correctly
and then um of course they've had the tv
show
we met ryan who played him on nbc and
would then reappear
an arrow in legends of tomorrow right so
this would be
brand new or is this are they going for
keanu or something
they are not going for keanu um i think
the plan is there's a british novelist
named guy bolton who's writing the pilot
and they're aiming to cast an actor of
color as
john constantine oh right on that's
that's going to be the flip um i don't
think we will see
this constantine kind comes in time why
do you found boston time that's the
third time now because that is how alan
moore pronounced it
is that right yeah he was never
constantine he was constantine
classic yeah um but
lady joanna constantine will appear in
sandman on netflix at some point
so we you know this would this only be
the first constant time we see
on screen coming coming soon but yeah
ooh it's it's crazy man like what was
the guy's name matt ryan who played it
like he mainstreamed him he played he pl
his version of constantine
sorry constant time um see it was very
very close to the one that i remember
reading
um even in the pages of uh of swamp
thing
they didn't let them smoke if i remember
correctly no i don't think they did
but um but yeah no i'm i'm here for it
and i know that
bad robot and warner media are very
invested in making justice league dark
happen
and it feels like this might be the
beginnings of their way into
making their whole their version of
magic universes
come to fruition um i'm all for it man
hbo max them and that disney plus app
they can have all my [ __ ] money
i spend i spend a lot of time watching
well i'll spend a lot of time watching
one program over and over on disney club
um and then the other one but that just
ended and then i'll watch the other one
i mean
they're doing it right man they're
hooking me like you know just as the
mandalorian ends
wanda vision begins just as one division
ends falcon begins
just as falcon ends you know [ __ ]
loki's gonna begin
just keep doing that until one day i
drop dead just
make sure there's always a marvel thing
that i could sit there and watch and
enjoy i can watch with my wife
she's that i can't believe how into this
[ __ ] show she is
so much so that she's like well i don't
understand which maybe we should watch
age of ultron i'm like
who are you and what happened we're
[ __ ] are we in stepford
how did oh and i love it too because
there's nothing better than somebody
who's like only this much interested and
you have this much information
that you could give them you go like i'm
constantly pausing it going like
you don't understand the importance of
this moment stan lee
and jack kirby created agatha harkness
yeah
you get to show off a little bit look
look at my big brain that is
hitting two four and useless to you i
know she was just like you know i
just thought this part of your
personality was [ __ ] stupid but
i can see now why people might enjoy you
that's amazing um elsewhere in the news
the most amazing video of the week
was a young actress named sasha calle
um discovering that she was cast
as supergirl in the upcoming flash movie
and i will 100 take every one of these
notifications like it's the joy that we
now get of zoom
this being the way that business is done
is that there's now a record of people
discovering their lives are about to
change
in ways that we've never actually been
able to be privy to before
and so watching watching this young
actress you know and andy andy machetti
who you know i don't know why i was
surprised that he was as fluent in
spanish as he is
but fair enough as he informs her
that she's been cast and she just loses
her mind and starts to cry
and then i start to cry and everything
is right with the world are we allowed
to watch it or will we get thrown off of
youtube
um we will probably get thrown off of
youtube soon because i think they're
just
out for us for reasons that
all i'm saying is grace randolph could
probably watch it
anybody else could watch it i don't know
what our [ __ ] problem is man
what did we do i don't know but that
video is adorable
um and it was you know super nice was
seeing uh
melissa uh benoist who is of course
supergirl but she's wrapping up her
supergirl run
um with this season of supergirl the
season uh the final season of supergirl
um like messaged her already and said
like you know there needs to be more of
us or something like that really really
it's lovely
very very sweet um because it's got to
be weird when you're like
uh playing a character and somebody's
like all right somebody's got
a suit they got to put it on next you
know like and granted it's not nearly
the same thing as the cw these are the
movies and stuff but still
nice to see a passing of the torch of
sorts and stuff
yeah it's always nice the peaceful
transfer of power
is always nice yes nobody swarmed cw
there was no like you know we got to
stop them from hiring this girl or
something like that
none of the other 425 actresses who
auditioned
like staged a coo
did he say it was 425 actresses yeah he
says i saw for
more than 400 auditions the us argentina
brazil
mexico colombia the talent pool was
truly amazing
and it was very hard to make a decision
but finally we found an actress who was
destined to play the role but yeah 425
actresses
nano 22 dot on
uh the chat just told us
uh andy machetti is argentine there you
go i'm sorry
argentine mark
because that's how alan moore says it
well played gov
um somebody said who's this uh hold on
oh [ __ ] i missed it but it was good i
can't i
can't find your name but they said
lakeith stanfield
has constant time that's a good
suggestion right now i would watch the
[ __ ] out of that
he's really good at unless unless you
can get me address elba
yeah look you're selling everything it's
just all been a one-man show called
marvel and he could play every character
and throw in a little luther for good
measure
um yes that video was absolutely
adorable
um i have a little video that i would
like to share
i could tell this is exciting for me
mark because for the last uh
few i mean we'll probably get thrown off
of youtube for showing this but um for
the last like uh
year changed two years i i've been
working on
masters of the universe i'm the only one
out there talking about it
because nobody else can right like
everybody else is worried they might get
fired
i don't care so i'm always out there
going like oh you're gonna love it and i
don't spoil it give out details i'm not
that stupid
i have never shown images and stuff but
i'm the only one out there flapping my
lips about it man
this week finally for the first time and
i was so charmed by this
somebody else talked about masters of
the universe
what is this person mr smith let's uh
let's bring jc in and maybe he can
help us out with this jc
are you did you quit our show there i'm
here
i'm done jc did you get that clip that
will
sent over yeah i've got it does anybody
know what the name of the show is it's
the show that mario lopez does access i
guess
is that what it is this was like his pun
i think it's his podcast
the pod is that an access podcast or is
it just like the mario lopez podcast
i think it might just be the marion it
was
delivered to me as the mario lopez
podcast
so uh sarah michelle gellar
buffy herself was on the uh the uh
mario lopez podcast i guess or it's
on with mario lopez
so she was uh promoting uh i believe a
food kitchen thing or something noble
she was promoting some good noble work
and
uh mario lopez brought up
feeding america project thank you
feeding america project she got good
heart
uh o-s-s-g-m
and when i say oh she's very young um
uh was it smg that went the other way
sarah did an interview and she talked
about
the show and this is gonna be a little
self-serving
in two degrees how long is this clip
jason
uh let me see
it's self-serving because she says nice
things about me i'm just gonna give you
a heads up
it's not why i pulled the clip i was
just delighted she talked about the show
at all
but i was also very touched that she
said nice things about me it's also
going to serve
um as uh you know something we could put
up so i could go fill my
[ __ ] water because i've got cotton
mouth like a son of a [ __ ] how long is
it jason 90 seconds
90 seconds all right kill us and show
this clip
this is uh sarah michelle gellar on the
uh
uh on with mario lopez um
talking about uh masters of the universe
check it out
i wanted to talk about you being part of
the new masters of the universe series
from netflix because i
love this cartoon when i was a kid uh it
was he-man in the masters of the
universe when i was
is he-man no longer involved or is he
just more of a secondary character or
what's the deal oh he-man is there
every okay you're going to freak it is
so good first of all kevin smith is
one of the best directors i've ever had
the opportunity to watch
his notes are just i i love this man so
much
and he has the same passion and when
every time like you'll get through
episodes and then another character will
pop up
so you're like wait that character's
back like every great character is back
but the story
is amazing i am so excited honestly i
haven't been this excited about
something in a long time
i love this so we're talking he-man ram
man skeletor
tila i remember these are off top of my
head i'm keela
you're dila that's awesome i'm so much
fun sarge
sergeant-at-arms tila yes
sergeant-at-accents right
remember evelyn there was man at arms
right there that's my father do you
remember evelyn
yes yes yes it's coming back
it's gonna be it's going to be so good
so much fun
it's really moving like i cried huh
wow well and kevin smith like d kevin
smith he's on our mount rushmore of
longest talkers yeah here are an
interview an hour interview
he's an hour it turned into like a
non-stop it was like a
filibuster he didn't want to leave then
he didn't want to leave we love it but
he has a lot of fun when uh
i thought i could talk oh kevin yeah
he's definitely our mount rushmore right
there
oh right sweet right
i mean oh my god i was touched but i
also was just
happy that uh the way she talked about
the show
um yeah that that was really that was
really cool
and uh and yes it'll be hard to fire
sarah michelle geller
um you can't really fire tila from the
tila show
no way man no way
and she was i thought it was adorable
when uh mario lopez was like naming
characters and she's like i'm tila
i'm tila it's like yes you are yes and
to correct
because i'm sure somebody will say it is
not actually the tila show
um it's not like we completely wrote 10
episodes that are about taylor
that's not the no it's everybody like
it's
just just heading you off of the past
comicbook.com
thank you well it's never them they're
good it's
yes somebody else but um yes no it's
it's very
um it's it's it's a he-man show but it's
more
masters of the universe it's all of them
our story
uses a lot of characters um and of
course
you know it's centered around the the
never-ending battle between uh he-man
and skeletor
naturally but yeah you know sarah as
tila she ain't getting fired she's a big
character um
how nice that she talked about like she
cried during it like i'm telling you
i cry like a son of a [ __ ] watching
this show over and [ __ ] over man
and i've read all the scripts i've
written some of them
like i've been involved in every shred
of production so it shouldn't work on me
but like i enjoy it so much man bears
score i've heard
four uh episode the score for uh
the first four episodes unfucking
believably good man
like i want to i want to spoil something
but i can't but like
there's a [ __ ] there's one theme that
is so incredibly
like metal and and i mean like [ __ ]
like because you know bear likes to you
can hear it and
i don't think i'm spoiling anything you
can hear it in the little clip that we
posted last week
it's not just instruments he's got like
oh
like [ __ ] singers and [ __ ] he he got
some
something going on in episode four that
is like
it's a lot of like oh oh it's [ __ ] so
metal
metal but uh so nice to hear somebody
talking about
masters of the universe that's not me
i think that it's a figment of my
imagination mark get used to it
something tells me that in the next year
lots of people will be talking about
massive universe besides you
fingers crossed it's so lovely you all
did such a great job where did he see
mark's episode
i would like to see that as well yes
i'm over there you come over here i'll
show you a lot of
them um all right news we got now we got
one more
um and i have been fully vaccinated so i
will happily come over to your house
have you gotten both shots i got both
shots i got my last one on thursday
did you get sick or feel sick at all um
i felt a little
weary it wasn't quite sick but i just
felt like tired
um a little bit of a nose runny thing
whatever my wife on the other
hand was like out for a day like chills
feverish body aches stomach aches all of
it it's like she caught the flu for a
day
um and it mostly went away and so now
she's fine but uh
but yeah i i can still do exactly what i
have been doing
which is wear a mask wash my hands
social distance
because you know this does not actually
protect you from getting the virus it
just keeps you from getting
devastatingly sick like it'll keep you
out of the hospital
right is what is what the the claim is
um
that's what we all want that's what we
all want for sure
um last new story um before we get into
q a
i mean this one this one stings a little
bit um for no other reason
um then i wanted to do it myself but
edgar wright
is readapting the running man
um saw that today yes the novel by
richard bachmann who
is actually stephen king which was
released as a paperback in 1982.
um the book is amazing the book is
nothing like the arnold schwarzenegger
movie
um but the book is really really smart
and it's really gritty and it's very
much about a desperate man
um who in order to to get medicine for
his wife and his child
um agrees to take part in this insane
televised game
which is way less um giant fat dude
singing opera
and uh and and and uh go-karts and
spandex and more
all you got to do is stay alive like you
can go anywhere in the world you want
but we're hunting you we have official
hunters and worse than that we are going
to incentivize
the public to turn you in so it is
like that game show [ __ ] that's in the
book that's in the book that is still
the core idea of it
which is like yeah you have to do video
testimonials every day but we're gonna
be hunting you and if you die
the longer you stay alive the more money
your family gets
um and if you stay alive for a week then
you win the game and nobody's ever
stayed alive for a week i'm not sure if
it's a week i don't remember the time
frame
um but i i love this book since i read
it
the very first thing that i ever wrote
in screenplay format
was an adaptation of the running man
that i just did to [ __ ] do it
i did it when i was like 24 years old
and uh and like i still have my copy of
the novel that's all marked up like i
highlighted all the the dialogue i
wanted to say
the chapters i knew i didn't want and
and yeah it was just like
kind of teach myself how to do it and i
always had in the back of my head like
man this this would be so great
like i'd love to do this it's like a
mini series
and uh it turns out that if you do not
act on the ideas that you have when you
have them
somebody else at the same place at the
same time has the same idea
and the person who does it first wins
that's not what it comes down to it
comes down to this
edgar wright is a [ __ ] dream killer
he kills your [ __ ] dream he took it
away from you the son of a [ __ ]
he comes over to this country from
england and he takes an american's job
edgar wright is one of the greatest
filmmakers ever born
uh sean of the dead is one of my
all-time top [ __ ] 50 favorite movies
probably
way higher than 50 and stuff like that
um
you know i i i'll watch anything he does
although i still have not
seen baby driver isn't that weird um
baby driver i like
quite a bit um some of the actors
notwithstanding but you know i kind of
that's why i bumped into it where i was
like
so yeah i i do got to give that a spin
but
um he's enormously uh talented so
talented so good and
everything i've heard he said he's also
a very nice guy he's a very very sweet
boy i mean
he's a grown ass man but i've known him
since he was a tablet um but yeah i so i
can't be angry about it because if
anybody's got to do it and if that
person doesn't get to be me
then i'm glad that it said go right and
i'm glad that it will be done with care
and paramount's doing it
and yeah did you know paul michael
glazer directed the original i did paul
michael glaser as in starsky and hutch
he was uh
a director and still is a you know did
he pass away i think he passed yeah he
passed away but he was a director like
right up to the end he also directed
a favorite movie of mine that like i get
[ __ ] on for liking this movie a lot but
uh the cutting edge topic
topic yes right [ __ ] it no
i know why were kelly saying topic man
doesn't get enough credit the americans
ministered yeah um yeah he was a uh
director man
um yeah there is one last news story
okay um danny elfman is reuniting with
sam rainey
to score doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
now that hey that's exciting b have they
stopped shooting this movie yet or have
they even started shooting are they
shooting now
um let's see filming began in november
2020
um and that was delayed about six months
um so i'm not sure when they are going
to wrap
but you know they could very well be
still in production and it wouldn't
surprise me if they are
um um they've worked together before so
um uh
somebody just said online that uh
paul michael glazier is still alive you
know is he yeah
no so we didn't kill him well that's
good i don't know why
him about it that's amazing yes i have
just gotten very sensitive
about being accurate and so barski is
not dead as warrior of genghis khan says
uh dr goat boy says it's david's soul
that died
i knew one of the it was hutch it was
one of the one of the two
paul michael glazer's 77 years old good
for him
um okay yes so [ __ ] danny elfin gets
to work with uh
sam raimi again yeah he didn't score for
spider-man didn't he
he did spider-man the entire spot two of
the spider-man trilogy
and as well for danny elfman or
sam raimi uh simple plan and as the
great and powerful
oh so he's worked with him a bunch yeah
this is this is reunion i
forget the score of a simple plan it's
so subtle yeah
but it's that movie that movie is a
[ __ ] that's a wonderful screenplay to
study a great piece of
of of directing and performance across
the boards
it's not it's the least rainiest
rainy movie there is probably but yeah
still sam's movie all the way through
but oh it's such a good flick man
yeah it feels it feels a bit like sam
was making his coen brothers movie
you know it's definitely got that feel
it's got that kind of blood simply feel
and he was tight with the kong brothers
man like yeah their boy they all came up
together and [ __ ] the one
in uh what is it uh hudsucker proxy the
guy in the elevator is based on
sam raimi hey buddy where you going
buddy oh buddy
that's that is sam raimi yeah i remember
reading you know
back in the day in fangoria i think it
was that
the cohen's helped out raymie making
evil dead in evil dead too like i think
maybe one of them had invented his shaky
cam
which is you know he would take a two by
four and then tape the camera to the two
by four and then
one person on each side would then run
with it and that was his
kind of low budget you know invented
macgyvered steadicam
yeah he's the guy that ran cameras and
[ __ ] man
yep um all right that is hot news
speaking of filmmakers i got one
uh who works for me man uh luke taylor
in my office
made two i only found out recently he
made two movies that are on amazon
prime what so yeah one is called
break do you have the artwork there jc
um and one is called um
uh it's got one of those long titles
of people's names hold on it is
winnie and charlotte last night at the
oasis
thank you thank you for saving me on
that one
um luke uh has been working with us you
might have run into him if you've gone
to any of the movies pop-ups
um and thank you by the way phoenix you
were incredibly
wonderful to us we just left the van
buren on february 14th was our last day
now we're heading up to vancouver it's
our uh
go to moviespopup.com if you're in
vancouver and you want to eat at movies
reservations now open
and then we're heading to orlando next
and we announce the orlando
dates and location uh next week but in
any event if you've been to any of our
pop-ups
uh luke is the guy selling you
merchandise and stuff like that
so uh he don't want to be doing that his
whole life of course naturally he wants
to be making films which he's done
already he's made two movies but this is
the adorable part
you go to amazon you check them out jc
will put the
the uh the links in the um uh
chat or whatever um so it's on prime i
think it's free if you're a prime member
or something i could be wrong
however uh lucas uh luke
luke's name is luke taylor and uh his
girlfriend's name
uh was taylor and then he married her
and now her name is
taylor taylor that's impressive isn't
that adorable
taylor's weird man taylor taylor so
taylor taylor is the star of his uh
two flicks t2 t2 very much t2
um so if you want to help out a fellow
filmmaker go watch it
uh luke's flicks and tell him kev sent
you and whatnot
um all right is that all the news we got
that is all the news we have my friend
mark wanted uh nothing more in this life
than to never be a news man but he
[ __ ] forces himself
back into that tiny ass box for you
every week give it up for marketing
today to the news i know these pants are
so tight
um all right jc come join us show
thyself
he's back again the ag of the harkness
of this [ __ ] there he is
you guys i the chat has been for three
weeks trying to get me to
banff in and out like nightcrawler does
and i just figured out how to do it so
next week if we do the show virtually
every time i pop in and out it'll be
like nightcrawler
oh that's so big
i figured out how to add the smoke so i
can't do it while we're streaming but
i'll have it ready for next week
uh i don't know if this is the case or
not but
tab 75 draws in chat
said david's soul is still alive too i
don't know if that's the case
we need a fact checker on this show
somebody standing by who could be like
we need ed kornacki up on the big board
you know to just literally
fact-check us as we go would be useful
um
all right this is the part of the show
ladies and gentlemen that most of the
audience always offers
a jeff's kiss too this is where we sit
around and answer
your questions you're responsible for
this part of the show ladies and
gentlemen
she's gone are we streaming and she's
gone are we she's me
i don't know she's gone i think i think
hold on one sec sorry guys hold on one
second
somewhere in the neither world super
echo they're saying
echo super echo
yeah okay so i'm not echoing
but when i no i am echoing my
it's like the sound card on my computer
just freaks out sound card on my
computer just freaks out sound card
what do we do leave you out of them
coming for you yeah no [ __ ] coming for
you yeah we knew we did something wrong
it's that sarah michelle yeller club
[Applause]
way too high for this guy
hi
kids
no questions
[Applause]
[Applause]
jeff's kiss
you